we've been learning about all sorts of
upcoming video games throughout June but
if you're an Xbox Live Gold member and
you want to know what you can play for
free in July I've got you covered
here's the new games with gold lineup
first out of the gate on Xbox one is WRC
8 FIA World Rally Championship that's a
mouthful to say but all you need to know
is that it's a rally racing game with a
hundred tracks each with varying weather
conditions you can start your engines
anytime in July as WRC 8 will be
available all month long Xbox ones other
free game takes the competition from the
racetrack to the basketball court dunk
Lords is a two-on-two game where you
don't just dribble the ball you equip
different gear to lay out the other team
as you throw up some pretty elaborate
dunks it'll be available from July 16th
through August 15 don't tune out just
yet
these 360 games are backwards compatible
for you Xbox one players - the first of
these is saints row 2 the second game
might not be as appreciated nowadays but
- is where the series started taking a
zini or direction you can expect to
drive a whole bunch of vehicles around
Stillwater as you explore the city with
your custom character Saints Row 2 will
be available from July 1st through the
15th
finally there's juju that's the name of
the pandabear shaman you'll be
controlling in this platformer Juju's
father has been taken by an ancient evil
and you'll have to use your mystical
skills to take down big bosses and bring
him back you've got a sidekick lizard to
help you out too juju will be available
from July 16th through the 31st and
those are your free games with gold for
July 2020 remember that you can always
check out gameplay clips and reviews for
these titles on GameSpot and stay tuned
as we report on the new games with gold
lineup every month
[Music]